[Music]
the lands of the birders are located
between the lands of the Khazar and
those of the bogus they are 15 days
march from the land of the Khazar they
obey the king of the chaos and supply
him with ten thousand horsemen they
recognized the authority of no chief
instead in each community are found one
or two old men whose opinion they seek
when quarrels arise
in principle however they submit to the
king of the Khazars their lands are vast
and they live in forests they
periodically raid the territories of the
bogus and the Pechenegs they are valiant
and brave their religion is like the
religion of the abuse they are handsome
good-looking and well-built if one of
them quarrels with another or suffers an
injustice or an intentional or
unintentional wound no reconciliation
between them is possible until the
injured party has taken vengeance when a
girl reaches marriage' belay j-- she is
no longer under the authority of her
father and confused any man she wants
the man comes and asks the father for
her hand and her father says yes or no
according to the wishes of his daughter
they have camels and cattle and lots of
honey most of their wealth comes from
Marten pelts they are divided into two
types one of which burns their dead and
the other endures them
their lands are flat and most of their
forests are callenge trees they
cultivate fields but most of their
wealth comes from Marten pelts and wolf
their territory is 17 days march in
length and breadth
[Music]
you
[Music]